biopharma presentations i am xavier
gutierrez of labyrinths and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by agilent
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send please address each
question to a specific speaker
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
and if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
i now present today speakers first we
have dr mimi roy
executive director of analytical science
at bio marine
pharmaceuticals presenting on the
influence of mass spectrometry
and development of host cell protein
monitoring
program for pharmaceutical development
next we will hear from dr raul rahman
research scientist at massachusetts
institute of technology mit on
integrated analytical characterization
of highly heterogeneous drugs
for a complete biography on dr mimi roy
and dr raul rahman
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr mimi roy you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone thank you for your time and
for listening in today
um i'd like to speak to you about
advances in the analysis of host
cell proteins in drug development of
biologics as well as gene therapy
like to focus a little bit on how new
tools in
mass spectrometry have been so
advancing so quickly and how
these advances can be utilized to come
up with
better tools for analyzing
manufacturing processes so
the influence of mass spectrometry
on host cell monitoring has been
tremendous
the advances in mass spectrometry can be
compared to
advances in how our cell phones have
evolved over
the last decade and and and there's so
many new things we can do with these uh
technology advancements so um
how can we use this technology for the
analysis
of impurities which are coming from the
host cell
that is used to manufacture biologic
so in today's talk i'll be outlining
some of the technology for doing
identification of host cell proteins
and also doing relative quantification
using mass spectrometry
i'll be focusing first on applications
that are directly utilized to
enumerate host cell proteins through
identity or quantity
and after that i'll speak a little bit
about a very interesting topic in the
field which is
determining the antibody coverage of
host cell proteins
so assessing the quality of the antibody
reagents that are used
in commercial release for example and
then i'll be moving on to doing
some absolute quantification of
uh host cell proteins so once you know
which proteins you want to
monitor you can actually quantify them
and
that can also be done using mass
spectrometry
and finally i'd like to end with a
example
maybe a couple of examples of how one
can also use mass spectrometry for root
cause
analysis in case there are hitches
in the process development before we
have a final manufacturing process so
um as you all know um in drug substance
manufacturing the identification of host
cell proteins is a critical piece
and mass spectrometry not only allows us
to identify
and give names to these proteins but
also quantify
the amounts of these proteins relative
to the desirable drug substance
and going on to the next slide
the typical approaches for host cell
protein analysis
so so far have been focused on
an elisa approach which is where you use
antibodies
and you take the drug substance in some
kind of a form
before it's completely purified so the
harvest or one of the purification
steps and you inject that into animals
and you elicit an antibody response
then you collect the antibodies and
using those
whole cell protein antibodies you make
an elisa
and then that elisa can be used in a
commercial process rather
inexpensively and reliably there are
some
issues with the elisa one of them is
that there is no
assessment of what the identities of
these host cell proteins are
and the identities can give us some idea
of safety
and they can also give us a good idea
of which manufacturing process step
might be
an issue if things are not going well so
there are advantages of knowing
what are the identities of these host
cell proteins that are impurities
and since the elisa cannot do that
what we've been doing is using mass
spectrometry to assess
the identity of these the advantage of
mass spectrometry
is that not only can it identify host
cell proteins but it can also
quantify them with respect to
a relative quantitation compared to the
drug substance
and also an absolute quantitation so
that you can have an absolute number
and a limit um for what's acceptable and
not
so the other advantage is that host cell
proteins can be monitored
monitored by mass spectrometry just as
in elisa
by monitoring many many proteins all at
the same time
so there is a multiplexing capability
that has become
very very popular recently
the typical approach in terms of mass
spec technology
is that we still rely on accurate and
sensitive detection
of peptides by doing a tryptic digestion
so we take the therapeutic protein and
usually any protein even it's if it's
purified very very well
has some residual host cell proteins
and these might be very very small
quantities but they might still be there
because they either have a affinity to
the
protein the drug substance itself or
they may be
sharing qualities of the drug substance
so that they coelude in a purification
step
so what we can do is take these in
process
or drug substance samples and digest
them and
subject them to lc msms
and lcms there are multitude of methods
within mass spectrometry that can be
used one can use
proteomic style methods where you can do
a label-free quantitation you could do
labeling and do quantitation regardless
you end up with a whole bunch of mass
spectra
of these proteins that are separated
chroma
by chromatography and then measured
using accurate mass
and msms which is your fragmentation
pattern that allows you
to figure out what the peptide sequence
is
once the sequence is known we can match
that with the database
and figure out what protein that peptide
belongs to
so in terms of chromatography there are
many options these days there's the
traditional
one-dimensional chromatography popular
methods
are just doing a reverse phase on the
peptides that's
something an analytical chemist is
usually
quite comfortable doing so that's an
option
if one goes into wanting a deeper look
at what's present in the sample
then 2d chromatography becomes a really
good option
these days it's quite nice to use high
ph reverse phase referred to here as
hprp
and this kind of method allows you to do
online
reverse phase of two kinds that are
slightly different so you get a little
more coverage
through the 2d chromatography you could
also do
something like a strong cation exchange
or scx
one of the disadvantages of this is that
you almost
always need salt and then after the 1d
separation you have to remove the salt
and often this leads to removal of some
of the analytes
themselves as you go through desalting
procedures
whether you use 1d or 2d lcms
ms it should rely on
you know the experiment itself if you
want to
find the really really small amounts of
cell proteins then 2d would be
recommended but if you're just trying to
assess something
without a very deep look then 1d should
be sufficient
one of the choices that i found in my
experience makes quite a bit of
difference is choosing the database
that you want to search your mass spec
msms data against
the msms data refers to fragmentation
data
this is the data that allows you to
actually get an identity
and the identity it relies on previous
knowledge on knowledge
as to what proteins are present in a
given organism
so if you are using cho cells for
example
then a cho database is needed if you're
using
an insect cell line then an insect cell
line database is needed
if you're using e coli then an e coli
database is needed regardless of the
database
it's advisable to add the protein
sequences that you know
are in addition to the database going to
be present in your sample this could be
the sequence of the drug substance
it could be mutations of the drug
substance if you know
those are present it could include
possibility of searching
post-translational modifications
as well while we're handling samples in
the lab
we know that some of the keratin from
the garments silk garments that one may
be wearing
or by touching samples without gloves
one can get keratin as a hit so
it's good to actually include it in the
database so that
you can identify these and then these
peaks don't get
searched against you know other proteins
for example and give you some kind of a
score that's not reliable there's
also the addition of proteins that might
be specific
to a given cell line that you're using
that are specific to that manufacturing
or process development
exercise and if it's cho cells for
example you might also want to
add a rat and mouse database a rodent
database
and i would always do searches with
multiple
search engines some of the
products that are out there right now
are agnostic of the mass spec vendor
you can go in and do searches with the
same software
using multiple kinds of mass specs and
you can also do
multiple kinds of search engines and
there's software available for merging
all of that data once you have all of
that data
what it looks like is that you have
all of the ids but if you're interested
in relative quantitation
then it's quite important to do some of
the things really carefully
one of them is the chromatography to
have reproducible chromatography
it's quite important when you're
comparing samples
because as we all know as mass
spectrometrists
we have suppression of of signal
when you have a change in gradient and
different things are coming off at the
same time
from the column and going into the mass
spec then
the way the mass spec records the signal
and the intensity of that signal is
affected by
co-eluence so it
is really important to get
reproducibility and prove
to yourself as a scientist that the
setup you're using
is well under control this is just an
example
of three replicates and it's a uv
profile
because it's just the first step of a 2d
method
and you can see here that all of the
peaks are lining up quite well
and so if you are comparing two
different samples for example
then you would assume that the
suppression from a given
coaluting peak is similar in all of your
samples
and so the response factor won't be
inadvertently
suppressed in one sample versus another
due to irreproducible gradients
as we go into the second dimension what
you can see
here is even though you've done
reverse phase in the first dimension as
i showed
in the previous slide using a high ph
reverse phase gradient
you're seeing peaks elude in the
beginning and
the end of the chromatograms here
that's a bit of a trick that people use
it's uh using a pooling approach that
has been published before i'm happy to
tell you more about that in the q a
session if someone's interested
but basically what you can do is run
your sample
through the first dimension and collect
instead of collecting fractions eight
fractions in this case you could for
example collect
48 fractions and then you could pool
every fourth fraction and that way
you're
sampling different fractions with
different chromatography profiles from
the reverse phase
early elements elements in the middle
and aliens at the end and you're pooling
them
and that way you're really utilizing
your mass back time so you can see here
in e and f fractions you see quite a bit
of uh peptides eluding in the beginning
as well as
at the end um and that's achieved
by pooling so these are pooled fractions
and pooling can be done in many
different ways it's a topic
of its own very interesting but going on
to
how we can use these technologies the
comparison
of scx to hprp is shown here
and even if you combine mascot and
sequest or bionic
you know your favorite search engines
and put together a venn diagram of all
the proteins that
you've identified that are not
the drug the drug that's being
manufactured
so they're all the host cell proteins
then you can see
that depending on the first dimensional
method
you get different amounts of proteins in
this case i'm showing
what i've typically seen in the past
which is that
high ph reverse phase does give us a
little more coverage
however scx gives you proteins that are
not covered by hprp
and so if you really want to do a
detailed characterization of the
material
it's best to use both methods it's not a
whole lot of more effort because you're
just running that
1d chromatography separately and doing
desalting
after that you can combine all of the
material and then run it or you can run
it separately but you do get more ids
so let's focus a little bit on
what kinds of applications this
technology
can help so wholesale proteins
are obviously monitored as i explained
in drug substance
but also in in process samples and
that's the beauty of mass spec that
is hard to do with elisa with mass spec
you can get go
all the way up to the harvest and
understand
how the sample and the content of the
sample is changing
through the purification process
one of the common examples shown here
is when you do affinity purification
and then you do lcm sms to look at
what proteins in your drug substance
are being pulled down by the affinity
purification
in this case if you've taken some
antibodies let's say that you outsource
to a company to make
and now you just want to enumerate what
are the proteins that this antibody
binds to that are present
in your process you could apply these
antibodies to
an in-process sample intermediate sample
or to the drug substance and once you
have these
anti-host cell protein antibodies you
can
use these to bind the host subproteins
and the drug substance you can do a pull
down
and immunity affinity purification
and then you can subject this to lcm sms
and elucidate
the identity and amounts of these
proteins
you can also compare 1d and 2d to decide
which approach to take with your actual
samples
and you can see what kind of coverage
you're getting and and that can help you
decide how deep you want to go in your
analysis because
deeper analysis is more effort and more
resources
so if you're resource trapped you can do
1d but you can do a quick evaluation
and compare this so in this case we see
that
there are seven proteins common to both
but
there are actually eight proteins that
you see in the 1d that you don't see in
the 2d
and vice versa so one of the issues is
that when you process samples more
you do lose a little bit in the process
and so
this is just an example where if you did
2d you would get a lot more coverage as
i mentioned before
you can use this technology to follow a
process you can
try to understand how to improve
the purification process you can try to
understand which
those cell proteins are removed as at
which step
of a purification process for example
and so this is showing in process steps
let's call them one two three and four
and what we've done is
measured the number of hcps that we see
by mass spectrometry
and you can easily see from the data
that
before purification starts you see a
whole bunch of other proteins and
this is 1d data if you do 2d you
probably see
you know hundreds of proteins but as you
go through the purification
step you can see how these are removed
and you can in fact know which ones are
removed when
so that if in commercial if you
inadvertently see an impurity that's
unexpected
you can actually look up that impurity
by
doing an msms on that impurity peak
and go back and see which process step
is failing
and then you can troubleshoot these
kinds of process
issues so you can see here we're going
from many many
hcps through the process and showing
very nice
process control and purification
efficiency
this is another step to show similar
data and you can see
that as we go through purification the
number of hits and the number of
spectral count numbers or psms
that you get increases as you go from
step one to step
four and you're enriching further and
further
as you go down the purification process
and this is completely expected
but you could use this data to compare
two different purification strategies
and see which
column revo removes more host cell
proteins or
which column removes host cell proteins
that you know are deleterious to have
for example
this is a comparison of how a drug
substance
which is purified by two different
purification processes
looks when subjected to hcp analysis by
mass spec
you can see that process a has 26 of
cell proteins
and process b has only one and so
if one is as one should be
caring about patient safety in drug
development
then obviously the choice should be
process b
which ensures that there are very very
few just
one wholesale protein remaining
and then one has to make sure that one
can measure the levels of these and make
sure they're
extremely low and acceptable so
this kind of data has been obtained by a
2d lcm sms
process and what this shows is when you
see only
one residual hcp by 2d lcms
ms that the process engineers have done
a terrific job with developing
process b and this process could be
preferred
in their decision making in
collaboration with analytics
these are just the numbers comparing
hcps to eliza's
in ppm so as i mentioned before eliza's
don't tell you what is there
but they're pretty good at assessing the
total quantity of
all um hcps that the eliza is able to
measure
and one can compare these and get an
idea of
you know how the two different
orthogonal methods
of measuring hcps track and they track
very nicely together so it's nice to see
that
we can also compare manufacturing
of the same process done at two
different sites
process engineers and
process validation engineers and people
who work with
transfer of processes are well aware
that
making a biologic at a new site is not a
joke
it's quite difficult to get exactly the
same process
and good analytics high resolution
analytics
using mass spectrometry can be so so
informative
to understand the difference in
manufacturing of the same drug substance
using the same process
at two different sites where there might
be some differences in the equipment
or in the operation details
and so on so this is a an example
of comparing two sites and what you can
see is
the two sides are really quite
comparable because
they both can give you uh similar
uh hcp uh you know
hcp content in the drug substance and
you can see
that cyto has 13 hcps side b has 14
hcps but 12 of them are common
so we would call this quite comparable
and you would also have data on the
identity
of these proteins and as i've mentioned
before
if you map out which protein is removed
at which step
you can actually troubles troubleshoot
this and
come up with a you know an absolutely
identical process if you have to
one of the examples of using
mass spectrometry that is my favorite
in this field is actually
not just using host cell proteins
directly
as the analyte and understanding what
they are and how much of them are
present
but to really have that conversation
with the commercial strategy
and the quality groups in the
departments
where these processes and testing are
developed
to see if the elisa is the preferred
method for commercial release because
it's
commercially a very well established
technology and it's inexpensive it's
reproducible it's highly sensitive
then the most important application
of mass spectrometry actually falls in
understanding the elisa and
understanding
what are the host cell proteins that are
recognized
by the antibody the anti-hcp antibody
that is being utilized
in the given assay
so for this the regulatory
authorities expect commercial
development
development and commercial release to
assess the antibody coverage
of the host cell protein antibodies
being used
and to really make sure that the
coverage is not
low typically i've seen 30 or 50 percent
coverage to be considered quite low by
the regulators because
basically that's saying that only half
of the
wholesale proteins that are actually
present are recognized by the antibodies
so we're blinded to the other half and
that's not a very good analytical method
it's nice to have something above i
would say about 70 percent
and the higher the better because this
is
uh ensuring that the antibodies that we
use
are highly sensitive and selective
for the impurities that we're trying to
make sure are controlled and monitored
this is a traditional methodology and
for those of you who are mass
spectrometrists
i'll go through it a little bit in
detail so that
you know if it's of interest then you
can think a little bit more about it
so on the left panel is shown a 2d gel
so this is no different than doing a 2d
lcms
ms where you have an enumeration of all
the proteins that are present in a
sample
and so with antibodies what you could do
is compare the proteins
that you see in a 2d gel in your
material
so let's say you're using a harvest
material
to inject into animals and elicit an
antibody response
and then you're going to use those
antibodies as your reagent for the elisa
then to measure the coverage of these
antibodies you need to compare
the total amount of protein in
the harvest to the proteins in the
harvest
that are recognized by the anti-hcp
antibodies so essentially the former is
assessed through the 2d gel which is on
the left
and the latter is assessed through the
2d western which is in the middle
and the way the assessment is done is by
overlaying these two images and
seeing which of the proteins that are
seen by the 2d gel that are indeed
present in the harvest are recognized by
the antibody
and showing their presence in the 2d
western
and by taking a fraction
of the numerator being those
peaks that are seen and recognized by
the antibody
and the denominator being the total
number of host cell proteins or spots
that are seen on the gel
you can get a percentage which
essentially is your coverage
now there are some issues with um the
traditional approach
running a 2d gel is actually technically
more difficult
than running a 2d lcm sms once you have
the mass spec
technology in place matching spots
between a 2d gel
and a 2d western is actually quite
difficult as you could see in the image
in the previous slide reproducibility is
one of the
biggest issues with 2d gels and
you know you always have to go to your
favorite um
you know ra to do this because not
everybody can do it so well so it's
quite subjective and
as scientists we want to have objective
methods you know we want to have
reproducibility in our measurements
regardless of who did the work
so um these are some of the limitations
the other limitations are that you just
lose you know the peptides you know so
if you have
something that's clipped and there's a
little peptide that might elicit an
antibody response
that may not be very safe for a patient
well you'll miss it in a 2d gel
you're also going to lose coverage of
the proteins that are very close to the
ds
because the ds is overwhelming in its
signal
now a 2d lcms ms approach helps a lot
with that
quantitation is also difficult and
what's a little bit frustrating to the
mass spectrometers
who knows all about identification of
proteins using mass spectrometry
is that this kind of technology gives
you no identification information
at all and that's a little bit
uh of a disconcerting
fact given that we have all of this
technology to do identification
the way we use mass spectrometry to do
coverage
is instead of doing a western we use
a column an affinity purification
so we have the antibodies on the column
and we pour the harvest through the
column and evaluate
the harvest which is equivalent to
looking at the 2d gel
and we evaluate the elliot which is
what didn't bind the antibody column
you could also sorry you could do the
flow through which didn't bind the
antibody column
and you could do the elevate which is
what bound the
antibody column and then was diluted out
if you do just an analysis of the
elevate
and the load you can get a very nice
estimate
of antibody coverage and we've done
these comparisons
for you know a column
followed by lcms ms to a more
traditional method with
2d um westerns and we found the numbers
to be
not very different but the nice thing
here is we have the identities
um so one of the
mysteries that we saw a while ago was
that when you look at the elevate
you start to see proteins that are not
in the harvest
we all know that mass cannot be created
or destroyed and so
the proteins that are measured in the
elevate must be going in in the harvest
and what we realized is that because
it's an affinity capture
there is a concentration effect so there
are proteins in the harvest which are
very low concentration
that may not get identified using even
the 2d lcm sms method
and when you go through the affinity
they get enriched and you start to see
them in the elevate but you don't see
them in the load
and what we've come up with as a
strategy is to
include those proteins in the load
so that you're not underestimating or
overestimating
um the antibody coverage because it's
really important to get that
estimate correctly
you can use these kind of antibody
assessment experiments to assess
which animal species a or species b
as shown in the left is better to
produce antibodies in
you can even compare individual animal
sera using these methods and you can
also compare
let's say a commercial antibody kit that
comes with the antibody that
is used in the kit and you can make your
own in-house reagents
and see if the enhanced reagent is
really much better
there are quite a few good commercial
antibody kits these days
and there's no reason to prefer an
in-house antibody reagent
if the commercial kit is giving you very
nice coverage already
however it's nice to have that data to
back up your decisions
and to make good decisions for
commercial assays so
we've been using these kinds of
technologies also to do
assessments of in-house versus
commercial
antibody reagent production decisions
going on to the second big topic for
today
um we also want to talk a little bit
about
absolute quantification so in the
previous examples we talked about
comparison so you see
two proteins here and 10 there and you
can make an assessment
you don't need to know how many
nanograms per ml of each protein is
present because that's
a lot more work however if you need to
you can do that
you can do that using multiple reaction
monitoring
typically using a triple quad instrument
the way this is done is you have the
same sample prep workflow but
instead of doing a discovery type or
proteomics type approach
you do a triple quad approach where
you've already
elucidated what proteins are in your
sample
and you build an mrm assay which is a
targeted
quantitative assay through the triple
quad what you can do is separate the
target peptide
do fragmentation in q2 and then
q3 you can choose the transitions
the fragment ions that lead you to the
signals for each transition
going from q1 to q3
and you can develop a target peptide
multiple reaction monitoring assay
in our hands we've been able to monitor
400 proteins in a complex sample
at the same time so this is very doable
what you can do also is synthesize the
peptides and develop
standards so that you can have these
made usually outsourced
and you can have these outsourced and
made as heavy labeled entities
and you can have them at a quantified
amounts
so now you know when you add these and
spike them into your sample
what signal in your mrm corresponds to
what amount
and then you can use these to elucidate
the amounts of the unknown
peptides by unknown i mean the unknown
amounts of peptides not the unknown
identities of course because
you have a targeted assay you know the
identities
after aci optimization the final assay
will have
all of these transitions like you can
see in the bottom left
where each peak actually stands for a
given peptide and therefore given
protein
and you can have hundreds of these in
the modern
triple quads that we have
if one worries about the quality of the
assay one can
qualify these assays and validate
validate them as well
and this is just an example of how
stable these triple quads are
we have internal standard peptide 1 and
internal standard peptide 2
that are run along with the samples
for about 170 samples run over several
months and you can see
how beautifully consistent the signals
are and the cvs are
well below 10 for the first uh peptide
and below 10
also for the second so you can get quite
accurate assessments
the spiking of the heavy peptide as i
mentioned allows you to do absolute
quantitation and you can compare
the intensity of the unknown in this
case
the red peak compared to the blue peak
which is a spiked in heavy peptide and
therefore you can measure
the unknown red and come up with protein
concentration in nanograms per ml
in a process development scenario as
well as
in cases where there are surprising
peaks
in a purification process
you can figure out which step in the
purification
or even in the harvest is contributing
to a higher level of a given impurity
that might be an investigation
if you're looking at lots of ds and the
impurities
changing in amounts depending on the lot
as i'm showing in the next slide you can
do the mrm or a relative quantitation
and correlate the mass spec intensity
signals
of these peptides with all of the
process parameters that go into the
purification
for example there might be a ph
in a given step there may be you know a
column volume
a buffer could be many process
parameters
and you can do multivariate correlation
analysis as this
shown here and you can try to find
those process parameters that correlate
with showing up
of an impurity as shown in the next
example
we've chosen one purification step
parameter
on the right and you can see the blue
signal actually goes up for lots five
and six
so we can tell that lots one two three
four seven eight nine
ten are okay but there is something
going on with lot five and lot
six and so if we can take all of those
parameters
and then do the hcp analysis using mass
spec
we can actually find exactly the
identity
of the proteins that are showing up high
due to a change in the process parameter
we can use this to
correct the process we can use this to
understand
exactly which process step is an issue
by looking at the identity
of the protein having mapped the
processes with these hcps
so there's a lot of possibilities for
developing
robust processes so that one doesn't
have
any issues in commercial manufacturing
and also if there are site
specific issues or their issues with
you know cells in harvest having
growth problems or other things that
people do see
during process development then one can
correct them before building a final
robust
commercial process
so i hope i've convinced you that mass
spectrometry has developed to
the point that it's a fantastic tool
for analyzing all the way from harvest
to purification steps
and to the drug substance or drug
product
and these approaches are powerful in
identification
as well as quantification relative or
absolute
of host cell protease proteins and that
these are quite
powerful and they're powerful compared
to antibody
based methods but also they can be used
um with antibody based methods
so it's not a this or that but it's
really
a combination of power in both
approaches that can yield
the best of results the 2d lcm sms
approach provides much better separation
and because it spreads out in two
dimensions
the signal that one is going to see by
mass back
resulting in a deeper look at the
impurities if this is desired
and the affinity purification mass spec
provides
a very nice assessment a reliable
assessment
along with the assessment of quantities
as well as identities of hcps
and this kind of assessment of antibody
coverage is very very important for
regulators to see
to know that the commercial assay has
been developed
and is able to have good enough coverage
to have confidence
in commercial release proteins with poor
antibody coverage can also be identified
using these methods
and the commercial assays can be
supplemented
accordingly if needed the
mrm assay is a wonderful tool for doing
very quantitative assessments of host
cell proteins
they can be used to specifically monitor
given impurity to
also support root cause analysis
during process development thank you
very much
and if you have any questions i hope i
can
answer them to your satisfaction in the
q a session
thank you for listening so well good
morning everyone
so um so um thanks for
the uh introduction and this uh
sort of great virtual meeting i'm
sort of glad to be able to present our
work
so i'm rahul rahman i'm from the sasi
sacrament lab
and i'll be talking about the integrated
characterization of biopharmaceuticals
and
this work uh has been sort of largely in
part from a
sort of a a thought leader award that uh
ram sashi sacram
i was a professor at mit uh sort of got
from agilent
um in really trying to sort of move the
field forward and move the needle in
terms of using
the agilent uh equipments for uh
sort of uh these the this to sort of
come up with
some very important workflows for
characterization of biopharmaceuticals
so when you look at biopharmaceuticals
in terms of the
the biologics so clearly you know they
are obviously complex
molecules and the way we think about it
in terms of the complexity
is sort of coming along these two two
axis so
the first axis is really looking at
you're going from your starting material
which is the uh cell line plus vector
through the upstream to the downstream
to get your drug substance drug product
so clearly a lot of parameters going
from the starting material heterogeneity
in terms of the
cell state the genetic stability culture
conditions the upstream downstream
process steps influence some of the key
product attributes and definitely
establishing these relationships between
the starting material process to product
is a very important
aspect of the biopharmaceutical
development
and the other axis that we sort of focus
on
is going from these product attributes
to quality
in terms of both from an efficacy
standpoint with respect to the antigen
binding
the effect of functions and specific
aspects of safety
in the standpoint of immunogenicity uh
you know aggregation
and any other issues with the product
that could potentially lead to adverse
events so so clearly looking at this in
the context of process to product
and product to quality is the way we
want to sort of address
uh understanding deriving these
relationships to address the complexity
uh in biologics and the key part of
doing that
is through uh you know developing
integrated
analytical uh workflows so when we
look at integrated uh analytics so
clearly uh
there is uh you know there are obviously
many ways of
defining it but from our perspective
we kind of look at it again as at two
levels
so as you know from many regulatory
uh considerations there is always a push
to develop
orthogonal methods and integrated
methods
so sort of our perspective is when you
take any
attributes in terms of a specific
structural attribute
the way we would like to think about
orthogonality or integration
is to have multiple measurements that
are pertaining to the same
attribute at a given heterogeneity layer
of the mixture
so one example is if you're taking at
n-terminal modification like
pyroglutamate
so you can use the peptide mapping as
well as an
orthogonal chemical approach like nmr to
sort of have correlative
uh readouts to pyroglutamide content and
and
in another example when you look at you
know the complex glycosylation
modifications and you release
your glycans and you want to
characterize them they are again having
both like a mass signature as well as
a chemical signature from linkage and
linkage abundance from nmr
can provide very important orthogonal
correlative measurements for
a given attribute so another uh
way of looking at integrated analytics
is to
obviously look at the same attribute
across
different layers of heterogeneity of the
molecule
so in this context clearly if you take
glycans as an example and i'll
walk through this a little bit more in
detail uh in the later part of the talk
is you can obviously define uh you know
glycan structure and
like an uh a glycan modification
at the level of the intact molecule like
if you take an antibody at the level of
the intact
antibody glycoforms and you can define
it at this
the next layer which is sort of the
glycopeptides that is once you fragment
the antibodies into peptides and
glycopeptides
and then at the under under the third
layer you can look at it as if you
release all the glycans from the
antibody and characterize them
so depending on how well you define
these layers as top down and bottom up
the ability to correlate very specific
aspects of the glycan
modifications across these different
layers
become another important aspect of this
integrated
analytics so some of the advantages of
looking at
analytics and and these data cross
correlations from orthogonal methods
is it really overcomes the limitation of
any single method in terms of
sensitivity
and resolution to sort of accurately
measure
an attribute and and and how to define
the sort of the process to product and
product quality relationships
by just relying on sort of just a single
measurement so it really
sort of removes that bias and and gives
a more robust
way of defining these attributes in
order to sort of measure these
key relationships so um
so given that we had these sort of
perspective um and and with all the uh
successes that our lab has had in
characterization of complex molecules uh
such as polysaccharides
and and also looking at development
strategies and taking the
molecules to sort of rapid development
path
so agilent actually uh recognized uh
professor ram sassy sacram
and the sassy sacrament lab to provide
this thought leader award
and uh an an important part of the
thought leader award was obviously to
sort of come up with uh important
workflows uh using
um agilent's uh state-of-the-art
instrument
uh to sort of characterize uh monoclonal
antibodies so as many of you know
monoclonal antibodies have heavy chain
light chain
and their source of heterogeneity from a
from a product standpoint can come from
a whole host of
modifications uh including uh you know
glycosylation
you know the ambition backbone
modifications
disulfide shuffling and the whole host
and each of these modifications
provide unique signatures when we look
at
both process to product relationships as
well as product to
quality relationships so when we set out
to
uh sort of implement these objectives in
the thought leader award so
the first thing we wanted to do is
obviously lay this out into some sort of
a map
where we look at the attributes at
various levels from
biophysical biochemical to the protein
sequence structure and
backbone modification and actually have
what are the kind of heterogeneity that
we are expecting to see
and what is the impact in terms of uh at
what level from
the process to product or the product or
quality
that these attributes would impact and
what are some of the analytical methods
uh both from the standpoint of
orthogonality
um and measuring across the different
layers of heterogeneity
that we need to have in place to sort of
measure these attributes
so one example again is if you take
glycation or deamidation
they're very important signatures of
cell culture glycation is a very
important
signature of cell culture cell culture
medium
and it's a pretty good signature for us
as fingerprints and it can also
look at it from the standpoint of
stability and downstream
and the overall product quality in a
similar manner if you take the a
mediation
of asparagines again they play a very
important role in structure function
depending on the location of some of
these residues at the
key interface of epidural paratroop
interfaces
and again they provide important
signatures of both downstream process
and formulation as well as
product quality so when you go to more
complex modifications of these
antibodies so clearly glycosylation
is a pretty complex modification because
the glycans are very heterogeneous uh
both from a chemical as well as from a
topological standpoint
and they play a very important role so
the given the
nature of these glycan modifications
like terminal stylization or core fuel
oscillation
play a key role in in sort of regulating
the half-life of the antibodies
regulating effective functions such
as antibody dependent cellular
cytotoxicity
so sort of monitoring these
glycosylation as a function of
both the process product and product
quality axis
become very important so having the
right set of tools to
sort of develop these correlations
become uh
very important from the standpoint of
the integrated characterization of these
biopharmaceutical products so with this
sort of uh
a map of what we need to measure and
what are the kind of
uh capabilities that we need so uh we
work with agilent and they
sort of gave us this this really cool
set of
instruments which at that time were sort
of the state of the art
uh which includes the 1260 bio inert
hplc and another hplc with a very
specific
uh functionality to do sec with a multi
array including light scattering to look
at uh the aggregation properties as well
as high molecular weight low molecular
weight species
and of course the coolest toy which is
our favorite is the uh
1290 infinity to uplc linked to
i think what was at that time really the
state-of-the-art acute of ms because i
think uh
at that time when we got this instrument
only two other labs
uh including a test lab added so and we
are
pretty pleased with this instrument in
terms of the
the capability in analyzing the
biopharmaceuticals as it
will become evident uh in in the later
part of the talk
and the other instrument which they've
kind of used more from a
discovery standpoint is the whole assay
map bravo
which is an automated liquid sample
handler which enabled us to do a lot of
microtransfection
purification to do a rapid screening at
the level of intact antibodies to
sort of simultaneously derive some
critical attributes
across hundreds of designed antibodies
that would
really help in accelerating and
supporting our antibody
discovery efforts and of course along
with all that the
key supplies from the columns uh in
terms of all the various columns
required to do the analytics um
was uh thought you know generous to
offer
and the other important relationship in
in terms of agilent from this thought
leader is
it's not that it was just you know you
you have these tools you have these
columns and so you
sort of go to your stuff but they were
actually working with us
to see you know what are the
shortcomings in these tools you know how
can they improve the software how can
they improve the column chemistry
and so there was a sort of a pretty good
uh
sort of relationship in in the context
of
having a collaboration with them to
really
sort of make sure that these solutions
are robust for
industry standard bio pharmaceutical
characterization
so the specific example we chose
in terms of looking at the
characterization using these tools is to
look at the nist
antibody so then this antibody is
actually
supplied by the national institute of
standards and technology
it's actually a humanized monoclonal igg
one kappa
antibody expressed in the mutant culture
and this has actually undergone industry
standard upstream downstream
purification and formulation and
it has also been extensively
characterized using
other analytical instruments including
thermal waters
and and and so there's an extensive
amount of
reference data available in several
publications for this antibody
so it provides us with an uh sort of an
example to
both validate our workflows as well as
sort of compare
what we've gotten with what some of the
other instruments
have offered and also provide this
feedback to agilent to just
make sure that you know whatever
technology that we are developing
is sort of on par with whatever
has been sort of published already about
this antibody
so in terms of uh
the antibody characteristics itself
again it's been
pretty well documented in terms of where
you have
these uh modifications uh both in terms
of glycation
oxidation which are the specific
residues that have all these properties
so
again with this wealth of information
you have a pretty good set of reference
data
for us to sort of compare and validate
our analytical workflows
and as i said there are multiple labs
with multiple instruments that have
analyzed this and
all these results have been published
actually
so um what i wanted to do is obviously
summarize
all the things we've done but focus very
specifically
on a particular aspect of the integrated
analytics with respect to the
glycosylation modifications that we've
done within this antibody
so we have obviously developed workflows
and validated them against the reference
data for the
intact antibody analysis the heavy chain
light chain subunit analysis
and then the for the full peptide
mapping and backbone modification
analysis
size variance charge variance uh and the
glycosylation analysis and um so this is
sort of extensive data that we are
actually
putting together with the help of
agilent into a compendium
to provide a sort of an additional
reference for this data using
all the agilent instruments so which
will
hopefully be published fairly soon
but one of the areas that i wanted to
focus on in today's
talk is to give you an example of how we
look at the
integrated analytics for characterizing
the glycosylation
so as i mentioned earlier the example
from from our perspective that we wanted
to showcase here
is how do you look at glycosylation at
the at the different layers of
heterogeneity
which is that the level of the
glycoforms at the
at the intact antibody level to sort of
the post-translational modifications at
the
glycopeptide level in terms of the
specific glycosylation
uh site that gets modified and the third
level
is once you release these glycan sort of
how do you characterize and quantify
them and how do you develop some of
these correlative relationships between
the
glycans characterized at these various
levels actually
so with the nist map there is only one
n-linked glycosylations right which is
the
the most common uh glycosylation site
across
the uh across most of the igg-1
antibodies which is at the under 300
asparagine
position so uh this this
slide talks about um how you actually do
the ides digestion to sort of separate
the fab
from the fc and given that the fc is the
one that has the single
n-link like oscillation side you kind of
get the
glycosylation at the intact domain level
in terms of looking at it
in the context of the lcms to look at
the various
glycoforms and sort of rank order what
are the
top like forms um as a part of this and
this is again consistent with what has
been reported with some of the other
uh mass spec instruments in the
literature
so the next level is looking at the
actual glycopeptide that has the
asparagine 300
so here instead of just cleaving the
antibody breaking just the antibody into
the fab and fc level
you do your typical peptide map like
trypsin and these other
sort of proteases to sort of break them
down into individual
peptides and glycopeptides and actually
do the lcms analysis of these glycopathy
of these peptides glycopeptides and the
way you do the peptide mapping
and the mass hunter software of agilent
is again pretty good in
sort of picking up these glycosylated
forms of the glycopeptides and actually
coming up with
a pretty accurate annotations of the
glycan topologies based on the mass
signatures of these glycopeptides so
this represents the layer of the
glycopeptide level
for the analysis of the glycan signature
and then the next level is of of course
looking at the released
glycans and so we released the glycans
using png asf given this
n-link glycosylation site and we sort of
label the glycans we've tried different
label forms including 2 a b and some of
the other labels
and we again use a highlight lc column
to do the lc and followed by lcms to
get a detailed read on the types of
glycans that have been released
from the antibody so as you can see
these are these sort of represent
different
types of samples that have been analyzed
but
the information contained in this is the
same which is
what are the distinct glycoforms or the
like the the glycoglycan structures that
are present as
a part of the post-translational
modification of the antibody
so what we are sort of in the process of
doing is to
sort of develop these correlative
measurements
where we kind of rank order these
glycoforms
and and actually see in terms of their
relative rank ordering at the level of
the intact structure at the level of the
glycopeptide and at the level of
the release glycans are you know sort of
the overall ranking maintained
which kind of gives the confidence of
the most abundant species to the lowest
abundant species and the distribution
of these glycophones at one level and it
also
we're also trying to calibrate it
broadly in terms of
what is the speed of the analytics
required to sort of get this ranking
like
obviously the ides followed by the
intact glycoform analysis is the fastest
method and clearly the glycopeptide
analysis from the data
processing is sort of a relatively
slower method where
the released glycogen is somewhere in
between so the reason
for also doing this is if we want to
build these type of correlations
for uh different uh biopharmaceutical
products so that
if you want to develop in process
control you can still rely on the fast
method
because we now have enough of a robust
understanding that
the rank ordering of these glycans would
be preserved
looking at it across the various layers
of analysis
and whatever changes or differences that
we can
pick with with either a process change
or something that is happening as an
in-process control
we can try to use some of these fast
methods to actually detect those and
develop those as
sort of important methods for the for
the process
development and the process product uh
correlation so these type of correlative
analysis is what we
uh want to sort of build in addition to
developing the workflows as a part of
the
integrated analytics platform
and the other types of correlations
which we can also
build is you know even looking at these
the
backbone modification variants where
when you look at charge variance
specifically with respect to the acidic
main peak and basic
variance in terms of just looking at
them through the column analysis
and you look at it more distinctly in
terms of backbone modification with
respect to
the cleavage of the c-terminal lysine or
the amidation
you can see a pretty good correlation
between looking at the charge variance
to the backbone modification again where
the information contained in the
backbone modification is richer
because you have more specificity but
the speed at which you can
sort of do some of these things at the
higher levels with respect to looking at
the
acidic and basic variants you can look
at it from the
sort of the lc analysis and sort of make
up these
correlations so um the
the main point is we are obviously doing
with the agilent instruments what is
sort of known in the industry
in terms of looking at all of these
modifications as critical
quality attributes but in addition we
are also trying to develop these
important correlations which will give
a good indicator of you know the product
drifts and other things that happened
during process development or during
stability analysis
to give this additional uh sort of
information
for sort of improving the product during
the product development
so the last few slides i just wanted to
focus on the
other aspect that i was saying which is
the assay map bravo which we have
you know obviously used for the sort of
a lot of our antibody discovery efforts
so the asima bravo is actually an
automated
liquid sample handler that i think
agilent
had sort of acquired and and developed
it quite well
so it has multiplexing uh capabilities
in terms of looking at three quality
attributes such as
yield aggregation uh you know sort of
uh and and and and this it works out for
96 well format that's compatible with
the sample handler to the lc system to
the lcms system so
that way you have cross platform
integration going from the
sample handler all the way to the
analytical instruments for these
multiplex readouts
and it also helps us permit sampling a
large grid
grid space of our designed antibodies
and rather than just looking at them as
displayed as cfvs we can actually
make them in sort of these micro
transfections into full antibody
structures and look at the
critical quality attributes and it is
also quite modular and it has
you know we've used it for discovery but
it can definitely be
the the scope of the application can go
towards looking at process development
looking at the building these
relationships between
process to product and the product of
quality
so somehow so the the typical workflow
that we've developed for
looking at uh you know our antibody
design and discovery is you know you
have these design constructs you make
them and you the
the the bottleneck right now for us is
to
actually do the 96 well transfection
which is little still manual but
that can very easily be automated
through a lot of these robotic
uh sort of transfection processes
and then the assay map bravo actually
has a protein a
micro purification and once you do the
mitral verification you actually have a
sort of a very small amounts of these
purified
antibodies which we can rapidly analyze
for multiple
attributes including yield and
expression uh looking at the
sec for like any aggregation and doing
all the quality checks with the
at least getting the intact mass and
mass analysis with the
uh with the lcms to do sequence
verification
and things like that so so in that
context uh
this assay map bravo has really been a
very important tool
as we looked at not just character
biopharmaceutical characterization but
also
discovering and developing new
antibodies
so i think this is sort of where we are
with all the agilent instruments that
we've gotten and uh i said they're in
the process of writing some of these
things up into
technical app notes and compendiums so
uh we'll uh
plan to publish all of this uh pretty
soon but i think this has been a very
good journey so far
in terms of working um with agilent and
we
sort of look forward to continuing this
collaboration
uh as it represents a key step towards
developing robust workflows for the
characterization of biopharmaceuticals
so with that
i'd like to uh acknowledge of course
agilent for the thought leader award and
the
ram sasi sacram who the recipient of
this award and
the members of the sashi sacrament lab
who are involved in this work
uh chengdu uh vidya subramanian and
andrew haters so i thank you for your
time and attention and uh
happy to take any questions thank you
roy and dr ramon for your informative
presentations
we'll now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen
now let's get started our first question
is going to be for mimi
actually um how can we
increase throughput of sample analysis
as well as data analysis
oh that's a wonderful question um
i guess uh we've talked about it a
little bit not in my talk but
in the recent one um that
um you know the assay map bravo
is one of those examples of a 96 well
platform where you can do sample prep
you could do
1d cleanup you could also do 2d cleanup
um you know do the first dimension of uh
chromatography
on the assay bravo instead of using a
column
and uh use different illusion buffers
for example
and so that's an example of just
increasing the throughput by sheer
automation
um one can use different mass spec
technologies as well like the
multiplexing of assays using mrm that's
a nice way to increase throughput
instead of following one or two proteins
um you know following many of them
at a time for data analysis we really
like
the mass center quant
option where you can do uh automated
analysis and
you can you know really increase the
throughput
of of your data
thank you and another question for you
are these synergies in detecting hcps
and product related attributes
oh yeah definitely um i think someone's
got their their mute
button undone i hope you can hear me
um so you can
look at um sorry can you repeat the
question one more time though oh yeah
absolutely
yeah it's okay are these synergies and
detecting hcps and product related
attributes
um yeah absolutely so the same aspect
methods that may be used
to look at post-cell proteins
for example identification of new
proteins
it's all based on fragmentation or based
on
some knowledge of a ptm and so on
and the same kind of technologies can be
used
to look at the product itself and
a lot of the modifications that a
product might have
some of the vulnerabilities of the
product which is something we really
want to get a good handle
on and you know really assess
critical quality attributes early on
um all of those uh can be done with very
similar technologies to what
we're talking about in the host cell
protein detect movies
thank you one more question for you mimi
um what are the aspects of these
technology that are most exciting for
the future
the most exciting thing for me is
really combining all of these
technologies and taking them to that
next
level of um process analytical
technologies
through in real time if possible so
um imagine a world where you would do
you know lot release with you know a
really
powerful peptide map that could follow
product quality as well as hostile
proteins
as well as you know some residuals all
in one aspect
um so mass spec has the capacity
to do that
well thank you so much um have a couple
questions for raul
uh what are the potential areas for
improvement of agilent
analytical tools
yeah hi so yeah i think the uh
agilent tools uh this is been sort of
developed very nicely for the
integration aspects like i said from the
sample handler to the analytics so
one area which i know we've worked with
them is uh
clearly sort of how to look at the the
data analysis
software to make them sort of more
compliant
for quality control um specifically you
know looking at monoisotopic masses
looking at
other areas of improved annotation for
glycosylation
when you compare with some of the other
uh
mass spec instruments that are there so
it is more to sort of work with them on
some of these software improvements and
the other areas have also been with the
column chemistry
uh where i know they've been constantly
trying to improve some of the
uh chemistries for like uh better
resolution of charge variants and some
of the other things
based on how that performs
compared to some of the other columns
for which this nist
uh data has been published so so um the
the good thing is we've been actively i
mean as a part of this award we've also
been actively working
to give some of this feedback so that
they can improve this to the
the next generation in terms of
improving
both from quality compliance as well as
a resolution
all the things that can be done
thank you another question for you uh
what advantage does assay matt bravo
offer for screening for antibody
quality yeah so
the the good thing about the assay map
bravo in a way
it's set up for the protein a is again
rather than looking at just
fab fragments or scfvs in a way you
would look at
the libraries uh one rapid read you get
with these sort of microtransfections
and i think
they can definitely be scaled with
robotics going
from nine to six well pledge to sort of
multiplexing formats
um that that you now have the entire
antibody with its properties
in in the in the system so when you're
looking at yields when you're looking at
sort of this aggregation you kind of get
an early readout on some of the
candidates
that may sort of pass in your antigen
binding uh
antigen binding affinity binning buckets
but you know they may
sort of have a very diverse profile in
terms of expression
or or some of these other aggregation
properties
and we've even tested that when you go
from the micro transfection to large
scale
that some of these properties do uh sort
of get amplified so you sort of get
early readouts at the entire intact
antibody level when you do the screening
to
sort of help pick uh good candidates
with uh with with a better uh developer
development path towards the therapeutic
one last question for for you raw uh for
complex modifications like glycosylation
what is the extent of characterization
that is needed and how does one look at
orthogonal tools
yeah so that's like obviously a big
question in the industry too so it
depends on
again um so this there's a trade-off
between resolution and speed
when it comes to glycosylation and from
a regulatory perspective you know what
becomes important
in terms of looking at the quality uh
and and the safety efficacy
becomes an important point like if you
take monoclonal antibodies
uh in in these typical manufacturing
chor cell lines
they have pretty standard glyco profiles
so
you don't need to go into the in-depth
in terms of the chemical linkage and
some of these other properties
unless you are engineering the glyco
forms for a very specific
effector function like you're sort of
removing the core fucosylation for
improved adcc
so depending on the kind of information
that you are looking for
you have to go to that extent of
analysis of of course
the more analysis you have the more
confident you are of the product given
that this is a pretty
complex modification but where it
becomes more apparent is if you're
changing
the expression cell line for some reason
where you get a better yield or you're
going to
say like other antibody formats like
bispecific antibodies or
fc fusion proteins so there you could
see
a lot more variability in the
glycosylation compared to what
is typically known for monoclonal
antibodies and cho expression systems
so that's where you would like to go
more detailed into sort of orthogonal
tools like
having enzymatic uh degradation profile
to get at specific linkages for stylic
acid or
uh you know even combine them with some
some analyses like nmr which i don't
think has been done
routinely but it offers a lot of
opportunity because nmr gives a pretty
good read on the chemical
linkage profile of glycans which you can
also sort of
uh add as an orthogonal tool to some of
these lc and ms systems depending on
you know that if you're really going to
a new platform new molecule that you
need to
characterize them more extensively to
sort of mitigate risk from a safety to
the actual quality of the molecule
thank you both for your answers do you
have any final comments for our audience
by chance
no i mean thanks for the opportunity i
think this is sort of the first time
i'm doing this uh sort of
the webinar i think uh it's uh worked
out very well with the pre-recordings
and uh
and you know thanks mimi for your
wonderful talk as well this is the talk
is
just listening to in this session and uh
and and yeah
i i hope uh this was a very useful
session for
for everyone who was signed on to it
well it was a pleasure to have both of
you in thank you again so much for your
time today and your important research
we really appreciate you
um before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through june of 2021.
until next time goodbye thank you so
much